horror unfall vor einer schule in
delmenhorst in der niedersachsen eben
gerade das sind zwei autos
zusammengestoßen ein auto schleuderte
dann in eine menschengruppe an der
bushaltestelle vor der schule ja und
dort standen zum zeitpunkt des unfalls
auch mehrere schüler es gibt mindestens
acht verletzte auch schwerverletzte und
vor ort ist jetzt unser kollege gerd
schröder garrett ja was kannst du uns
berichten was es dort genau passiert und
sind auch unter den verletzten kinder
das ist ja eine berufsschule leben uns
wurde unfall passiert ist genau hinter
uns steht der einen pkw der hier
verunfallt ist hier könne man ganz kurz
schauen das ist ein einen golf der
wollte ich hier auf dieser straße wenden
das ist eine straße in der nur 30 km h
erlaubt sind und dann kam von hinten ein
mercedes sportwagen der hier auf der
seite steht und ist in die seite herein
geprallt und dann ist der golf hier in
die bushaltestelle geschleudert und hier
standen personen offenbar auch schüler
von der berufsschule die zum teil von
trümmerteilen und von dem fahrzeug
getroffen worden sind wir sprechen hier
im moment von acht verletzten
wahrscheinlich drei personen schwer
verletzt darunter aber auch die fahrerin
von dem pkw neben mir steht albert säger
von der polizei in delmenhorst herr
seghers erzählt er ganz kurz ein
riesiges kräfteaufgebot auch hier ging
es genau vor ja wir haben hier gegen 11
uhr 30 einen notruf über den
polizeilichen notruf als auch über den
notruf der feuerwehr erhalten das ist
hier vor der berufsbildenden schule im
ricordo häufig in delmenhorst zu einem
verkehrsunfall gekommen sein soll im
ersten mitteilung wurde davon gesprochen
dass ein pkw in eine menschenmenge
gerast ist das hat natürlich dazu
geführt dass wir als polizei als auch
rettungskräfte und feuerwehr mit einem
großaufgebot an kräften hier vor ort
erschienen sind und vor ort dann
glücklicherweise müssen wir sagen erst
mal gesehen haben dass es sich um einen
handelsüblichen verkehrs unfall handelte
der hat sich dann nach stand jetzt so
zugetragen dass der im hintergrund zu
sehen vw auf dem weg von häufig
unterwegs war in richtung burggrafendamm
und hier auf dem rechtzeitigen
seitenstreifen angehalten ist um eine
person wahrscheinlich die tochter
aufzusammeln im anschluss an dieses
aufsammeln wollte die fahrzeugführerin
mit einem lied hören wieder auf den weg
ohne häufig in gegenrichtung
vorn fahren und hat dabei den von hinten
nahenden pkw des anderen beteiligten
hier übersehen es kam dann zum
zusammenstoß bei dem der mercedes
frontal in die fahrerseite des vw
gefahren ist wodurch natürlich erst mal
alle drei insassen verletzt wurden in
der folge wurden beide pkw dann zur
seite geschleudert der anfahrenden pkw
nach rechts in richtung bushaltestelle
als auch der auf die pkw häufig
unterwegs gewesene mercedes nach links
auf den gehweg dort wurden dann
insgesamt auch noch mal fünf personen
verletzt
das ganze klingt erstmal sehr dramatisch
ist aber man kann auch ein bisschen von
glück im unglück sprechen denn man sieht
wie die fahrzeuge zerstört worden sind
und wie die personen hier vor der schule
gestanden haben das hätte auch anders
aussehen können oder definitiv muss man
davon sprechen dass es hier wirklich
glück im unglück ist wenn wir uns die
schäden hier beim anfahrenden pkw
ansehen können wir wirklich von glück
reden dass die fahrzeugführerin
wahrscheinlich nur schwere verletzungen
erlitten hat und auch die schäden am
mercedes sind ja nicht wirklich nur
lappalien zusätzlich dann die
umherstehenden personen die durch die
pkw getroffen wurden und auch durch die
trümmerteile dass es da nur um leichte
verletzungen geht ist wirklich wirklich
glück im unglück also glück im unglück
hier bei diesem verkehrsunfall in der
mit horst und wir sehen jetzt hier auch
im hintergrund die polizei und auch ein
gutachter der die spuren aufnimmt weil
es muss herausgefunden werden
mit was für eine geschwindigkeit ist auf
der pkw gefahren denn hier vor der
schule ist eigentlich nur 30 km/h
erlaubt und der schaden der deutet
darauf hin dass hier deutlich schneller
gefahren wurde das ist ein unfassbares
drama eine mutter offenbar die ihr kind
abholen wollte geld von der schule und
dann ein you turn gemacht hat gewendet
ist und dann übersehen hat dass von
hinten jemand angefahren kommt beide
autos dann umstehende menschen
wahrscheinlich auch schüler getroffen
der uns einmal noch mit an dieser
unfallstelle das ist ja alles eben
gerade erst passiert die verletzten auch
zum teil schwer verletzt jetzt im
krankenhaus gibt es irgendwelche angaben
über das alter der verletzten sind
darunter schüler dieser berufsschule
die genau der opfer ist noch unklar
auch unklar ist auch wirklich schüler
von der schule waren es sieht ganz
danach aus weil die schule ist genau
hier der ausgang hier sammeln sich die
schüler auch um mit dem bus nach hause
zu fahren es handelt sich dabei um eine
berufsschule das heißt wir gehen davon
aus dass sich mindestens um jugendliche
gehandelt haben muss also nicht zu
kleine schüler weil die berufsschule
hier erst ab der zehnten klasse im
grunde stattfindet wir können wir ganz
kurz einmal schauen hier ist diese
straße und hier werden auch gerade von
seiten der polizei die spuren gesichert
das heißt hier sieht man auch die
ablenkt spur von dem mercedes die hier
führt und die zu der endposition von dem
erzählt ist hier führt und gerade wenn
wir den golf noch mal anschauen ich darf
ganze seite bitten dann sehen wir dass
der golf massiv zerstört worden ist in
der beifahrerseite das passiert nicht
bei einem aufprall mit 30 km h das ist
klar was ganz wichtig ist die leitstelle
hat hier auch gleich großalarm ausgelöst
das nennt sich also massenanfall an
verletzten ist wurden rettungswagen aus
der region zusammengezogen um die vielen
personen hier auch zu versorgen und
betreuen zu können zudem waren auch
notfallseelsorger vor ort um hier die
schüler die auch alleine zeuge des
unfalls wurden bestmöglich zu betreuen
und über das geschehen ist auch dann zu
reden um im endeffekt dass auch
verarbeiten zu können